A while ago I had an epiphany.
(chorus sings)
Because I had finally had a thought that perfectly articulated everything I had been feeling for months
and that thought was
"I feel like I don't deserve to be depressed."
I've been very open about the fact that my sister committed suicide
but I've never really talked about depression.
I made a very general video about it years ago
(where the color correction is cringe-worthy, I know)
but it was easier back then to recognize that I was depressed
because my sister was dead
I was self-medicating with alcohol and escaping with drugs
and I hated my job and I hated school
and I hated my life.
So was I depressed? Hell yes.
But now?  Now I have a career that's like picking up momentum.
Now I'm in a happy relationship with four furry cat children.
Now I feel like I have a purpose.
So now when I think:  "Am I depressed?"
A part of me is like: "Oh really?  What do you have to be depressed about?"
But this denial of it just makes me a shitty person to be around.
I'm just a shitty person to be around right now.
And why do I feel this way?  You know, why do I feel this weird sense of shame?
Like by being depressed I'm somehow being ungrateful.
Who or what is telling me that I should feel this way?
External factors are the keys to happiness and you have those right now so be happy!
Do I really think that if I talk to someone they're gonna say:
"So you think you're depressed?"
"Yea."
"How dare you."
"What?"
"Who do you think you are?"
"A human being?"
Does anyone else feel like this?
I feel like I don't deserve the label "depression"
because there are so many levels to it and the extreme side of it sucks.
At least now that I have this glorious insight
(chorus sings "Hallelujah")
I can actually do something about it.
So yay for epiphanies!
Woo!
I actually had one the other day when Los Angeles raised the legal cat limit from 3 to 5.
(gasps) I can have 5!
(chorus sings "Hallelujah")
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay Awesome Gotham.